joining me now Ohio Senator JD Vance
Senator your reaction to what the
speaker said I mean I think he does want
what you want on the border um I think
he's he really does want that um is this
the way to do it well I don't I don't
think so lur I think the speaker first
of all is right that we haven't seen the
details of the actual proposal they
releas them on Friday night then they're
voted on on Monday night we ex exactly
we know what's going to be in this thing
and we know that it will lack two
critical Provisions first of all does
nothing on parole Laura Barack Obama
paroled 5,000 illegal aliens a Year Joe
Biden is paroling close to a million per
year the proposal does nothing on parole
second it really does nothing on fixing
the Asylum process in our country so you
combine these two things you're not
actually addressing the Border crisis
and importantly and you saw speaker
Johnson addressed this and I appreciate
him for doing so this is fundamentally
about getting money for Ukraine this is
a border fig Leaf so that we can send
another $61 billion for Ukraine and I
just think it's such a catastrophic
abdication of leadership for Republicans
at the height of a significant border
crisis when the American people are with
us on the need to secure the border to
pretend that we're securing the border
with the one hand so we can give $61
billion to zalinsky with the other it's
atrocious it seems that we finally have
the blue City Mayors yes you know in in
a position where they understand this is
really bad and and instead you give them
a political rescue package that again is
meaningless because once you get that
bill and we don't have the text yet but
once you get that bill and there's
verific there'll be some verification
you know nonsense in it who's going to
who's going to make him do the
enforcement who well it's effectively
impossible and here here here's the real
tell that this is not fundamentally
going to secure the border is if you
really wanted to you know how I feel
about Ukraine I think we spent spent too
much money over there already but if you
really wanted to use Ukraine as a hook
you could tell Joe Biden we won't give
you another dime until you get illegal
border crossing to a very low number
below a, below 500 whatever the number
you pick is the fact that that's not on
the table tells you this is not about
border security it's about sending $61
billion to Ukraine now this was the
White House's priority uh before going
into the meeting today to your
point our Focus today the president's
Focus today is going to be about Ukraine
and the importance of continuing to
support Ukraine as they fight against
tyranny as they fight against uh
President Putin's aggression that's
going to be the focus and I said the
president is you know he brings people
together obviously is is willing to to
listen uh to what folks have to say but
that is the purpose as Ukraine uh and
those negotiations on the hill on the
Senate side is going to continue do you
actually think that there's quote
negotiations this thing was written
months ago this the lobbyists have their
goodie bag of of items on the border
front and obviously they already know
how much they money they want for
Ukraine but this is already done they
you have to sneak the the text out and
then you'll have like a you know what 5
hours to read it it'll be 800 pages long
well this is this is actual Classic this
is news lore because I actually agree
with the White House Press Secretary
about something that this is all about
Ukraine and you're exactly right about
the timing here what we've been told on
the Senate side is that this that the
details of this package will drop later
this week that could mean Friday night
and then we'd be expected to vote on it
a few days later immigration law L you
know this better than I do is so
complicated one provision over here
affects another provision over here the
idea you can do a real border security
package and actually review it and amend
it is insane you're negotiating with
people who do not believe a border is a
moral thing to have that's exactly right
Peri it's immoral to have a border and
the failure to recognize that and
actually use our leverage I think is a
huge mistake here Laura now Senator
always great to see you and really happy
the speaker came in hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else